Taylor Sterling is the world's fastest guitar player,
able to play Flight of the Bumblebee
at 999 beats per minute.
What the FAK?
The Facts and Knowledge on Speed.
Italian physicist Galileo was credited
with being the first to measure speed
by using the distance covered
and the time it takes.
Nothing is considered to go faster
than the speed of light
at 299,792,458 meters per second
which is the cornerstone
of Einstein's theory of relativity.
The first quantitative estimate
of the speed of light
was made in 1676 by Ole Romer.
It's plain to see the power of speed
when looking at tornados.
The fastest recorded tornado
was on May 3, 1999 in Oklahoma City.
The tornado had a wind speed
of 318 miles per hour.
When it comes to the animal kingdom,
the fastest on land is the cheetah.
It can run between 70 and 75 miles per hour
and has the ability to accelerate
from 0 to 68 in three seconds
which is faster than most cars.
In the water, the sailfish prevails
as the fastest swimmer
at around 70 miles per hour.
But the sky is where you'll find
the fastest animal of all.
The peregrine falcon is renowned for its speed
reaching over 200 miles per hour
during its high-speed dives.
While humans may not be able
to outrun a cheetah,
they can perform a variety
of tasks very quickly such as drumming.
George Urosevic of Australia
achieved 1553 drum beats in one minute.
There's some incredibly
fast rappers out there
including Twista and No Clue,
but here's Rebel XD
breaking a speed rapping record
by clocking in an impressive
683 syllables in 54.5 seconds.
[speed rapping]
Steve Whitmore beat out the famous micromachines guy
as the world's fastest talker.
He can say 637 words per minute.
[speed reading]
It's hard to talk when you're
shoving food in your face
as quickly as possible like Kobeyashi
who holds competitive eating records
in meatballs, Twinkies,
and several other foods.
Or like Peter Czerwinski, AKA Furious Pete.
He holds the record
for eating a whole raw onion
in 43.53 seconds.
And Joey Chesnut is the current champ
of the Nathan's hot dog eating contest,
winning six titles in a row,
devouring 68 hotdogs and buns in ten minutes.
Those guys might want to do some running
after digesting all that food,
but they'll never go as fast as Usain Bolt.
Born in 1986, the Jamaican sprinter
is a three-time Olympic gold medalist
for the 100 meter, 200 meters,
and the four by 100 relay.
He ran an incredible 27.79 miles per hour
during the 100-meter sprint.
Running through Super Mario Brothers
at a ridiculous speed
is Andrew Gardikis
who holds a world record
with 4 minutes and 58 seconds
to complete the entire game.
It's a speed run
without any cheats or assistance,
and the time
that he claims is unbeatable.
When it comes to unbeatable gunslingers,
there's Bob Munden.
Munden owns eighteen world records
for fast draw competition
with his unbelievably quick draw
being clocked at two one hundredths of a second.
Let's give him a round of applause,
courtesy of the fastest clapper.
Ken French clapped a world record
721 times in a minute
at a pace of about twelve claps per second.
If that doesn't blow your mind,
check out the world record
for solving a Rubik's Cube
blindfolded, 28.8 seconds.
When it comes to roller coasters,
the Formula Rossa
at Ferrari World in Abu Dhabi
outruns the competition.
It tops out at 150 miles per hour
and accelerate in about 4.9 seconds
using a hydraulic launch system.
Mitsubishi developed the fastest elevators.
They'll be located
in the Shanghai Tower in China,
and they travel 59 feet a second
and cover a distance of over 3000 feet per minute
which will eclipse the current fastest elevators
in the Taipei 101 Tower in Taiwan.
The world's fastest camera is being used
to detect rogue cancer cells.
The new optical microscope has the ability
to detect rare cells with the sensitivity
of one part per million in real time.
There's also a new player
in the world's fastest computer game
developed by IBM.
Sequoyah achieved 16.32 petaflops per second
using 1,572,874 cores.
Roughly capable of calculating in one hour
what it would take 6.7 billion people
using hand calculators
320 years of nonstop computing
to complete.
Topping out at 268 miles per hour,
the Bugatti Veyron Super Sport
is the world's fastest production car.
It boasts 1183 metric horsepower
and costs around two and a half million dollars.
The land speed record held by the Thrust SSC
broke the sound barrier with a speed
of 763 miles per hour.
But looking to demolish that record
is the Bloodhound SSC.
Sporting a jet and hybrid rocket,
the target of the supersonic car project
is 1000 miles per hour.
Currently holding the world record
for fastest train
is the MLX01,
a Japanese magnetic levitation train
capable of a maximum speed of 361 miles per hour.
The maximum speed in service
was set by the Shanghai Maglev Train
reaching 268 miles per hour
during its daily service.
When it comes to water speed records,
there's the spirit of Australia
reaching 317 miles per hour in 1978.
Rocky Robinson
set a world land speed record
for a two-wheel streamlined motorcycle
at 376 miles per hour.
Flying with incredible speed is
the North American X-15,
a rocket-powered aircraft
with the official world record for speed
topping out with a flight in 1967
that reached 4519 miles per hour.
And the X-15 flew so high
that pilots who reached an altitude
of fifty miles or more
were considered astronauts.
NASA has joined forces
with Boeing and Gulfstream
to create a supersonic jet
capable of flying
from London to Sydney in four hours.
The Concord Jet topped out
at about 1350 miles per hour
while this new one looks to reach
a top speed of 2500 miles per hour.
Finally, flying ludicrously fast
is the Falcon Hypersonic Technology Vehicle-2
developed by DARPA.
They're creating rocket-launched,
unmanned gliders
designed to fly 20 times
the speed of sound, or Mach 20,
which is about 13,000 miles per hour,
and their goal is to give the U.S.
a defense capability
of reaching and/or deploying
anywhere on Earth in an hour.
I'm going to leave you with this guy.
He set the first world motorcycle
speed record in 1903.
Who is he and how fast did he go?
Before we go, here is last video's winner.
Be sure to subscribe for more Vsauce 2,
and as always, thanks for watching.